Caption: so today we have Brandon Lewis Here
Caption: Brandon is going to talk to us about the
Caption: art of creative coding Brandon has been
Caption: developing software for about 20 years
Caption: and is currently a senior manager of
Caption: software engineering at one of perth's
Caption: largest mutuals he's presented
Caption: previously at DDD
Caption: and his previous chat was around uses of
Caption: blockchain outside of cryptocurrency
Caption: today he'll be exploring the question
Caption: can code create up over to you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: oh
Caption: thank you thanks very much
Caption: um wow it's a good turnout thank you
Caption: very much for for coming
Caption: um really appreciate you taking the time
Caption: uh before I start I just want to thank
Caption: the the sponsors for DDD Perth without
Caption: their generous support this event
Caption: wouldn't be possible
Caption: um so thank you very much for that
Caption: today what I really want to do is I I
Caption: have three objectives I'm hoping to sort
Caption: of inspire all of you to to try your
Caption: hand at creative art or creative or
Caption: generative art and create code or create
Caption: art with code
Caption: I'm going to show you some of the tools
Caption: that you might be able to use to do this
Caption: and some techniques some basic
Caption: techniques to sort of get you started
Caption: what you shouldn't expect is a math
Caption: master class so while there are there
Caption: are some relationships between
Caption: mathematics and creative coding I'm
Caption: still very much a student of maths more
Caption: so than a teacher so so don't expect any
Caption: any math secrets to be honest
Caption: um
Caption: and web 3 and nfts big topics of course
Caption: don't expect to learn how to get rich or
Caption: Dogecoin or with Dogecoin selling
Caption: Profile Pics that's that's not what
Caption: we're here for
Caption: a bit about me
Caption: uh I've been developing commercial
Caption: software for about 20 years I've been
Caption: coding for closer to 30 at this point
Caption: I've worked across the entire software
Caption: stack from front-end to back end and
Caption: everything in between I specialized in
Caption: integration for many many years before
Caption: moving into leadership roles and
Caption: proceeding with that my career
Caption: currently I'm a software engineering
Caption: manager at a large wa based Mutual where
Caption: I lead a bunch of awesome people to do
Caption: cool stuff and I support them in being
Caption: awesome
Caption: uh you can find me on all of the various
Caption: twitters and linkedins and and whatnot
Caption: and I blog about leadership in my my
Caption: blog at leaderkaizen.com
Caption: uh of course I being a leader I don't
Caption: really code all those all that much
Caption: anymore
Caption: um in my work day to day so I have to
Caption: get my coding kicks elsewhere and to do
Caption: that I usually create my own projects
Caption: and work on things on the side in my
Caption: spare time
Caption: that's sort of how I came to to get
Caption: involved with unity and and learn unity
Caption: and develop game prototypes with it I
Caption: really enjoy understanding how those
Caption: processes and Mechanics Work and seeing
Caption: if I can create them myself it's a good
Caption: learning experience and keeps my skills
Caption: um in current I suppose
Caption: uh it's also how I got into to Skaters
Caption: so uh from from unity and learning uh
Caption: mechanics and and developing those
Caption: things I got into Shader development
Caption: which is really another gateway to to
Caption: creative coding and how I got into that
Caption: some of the examples of shaders I've
Caption: created uh are things like
Caption: from Mr shaders for lava obscuring or
Caption: objects that are obscured and doing
Caption: outlines and and mixing uh messing with
Caption: things like Z buffer and whatnot to fake
Caption: uh fake um transparency and the like and
Caption: some Ripples and whatnot
Caption: but of course I haven't actually
Caption: finished a game and this tweet kind of
Caption: explains why uh that's that's kind of
Caption: that explains me really
Caption: but it turns out that my first
Caption: experience with creative coding was
Caption: actually many many years ago when I was
Caption: about nine years old
Caption: I joined a computer Club you know with
Caption: all the cool kids did right and got
Caption: introduced to logo uh in log with logo
Caption: you create you move a turtle around and
Caption: draw images on the screen and it's
Caption: actually used to to promote software
Caption: literacy and develop skills at a low
Caption: level
Caption: I didn't realize at the time of course
Caption: but it was um it was fun I suppose and
Caption: what I'd like to actually do is maybe uh
Caption: maybe share
Caption: some of the things that you could do
Caption: with logo because uh
Caption: that's pretty cool
Caption: um of course being
Caption: this is a logo interpreter developed in
Caption: in JS and JavaScript available freely
Caption: and online I'll have links and resources
Caption: at the end of the attender presentation
Caption: but of course being nine this is kind of
Caption: what I created right like
Caption: as you draw on a piece of paper
Caption: and of course when your skills are
Caption: limited uh and you don't really know
Caption: what you're doing you kind of just
Caption: chaos right just chaos
Caption: and just create all sorts of random
Caption: stuff that you think looks cool
Caption: but it wasn't it wasn't until recently
Caption: that I realized you could actually do
Caption: some pretty cool things like uh some
Caption: depictions of mathematical algorithms uh
Caption: in in logo itself and I I thought that
Caption: was pretty cool so this is a this is an
Caption: example of philotaxis which is a
Caption: um
Caption: it is the the way that leaves grow on
Caption: stems and plants so it's a it's a
Caption: biology biology thing which is tied to a
Caption: mathematical can be represented
Caption: mathematically and thus depicted in in
Caption: code
Caption: and I thought that was pretty cool
Caption: see sorry
Caption: technical issues
Caption: yeah
Caption: real technical issues
Caption: cool
Caption: sorry
Caption: Technology's evolved obviously since
Caption: since logo and the ability to create to
Caption: create such stuff is is a lot more
Caption: accessible and a lot easier to do
Caption: particularly with things available on
Caption: the web like you just saw I could do
Caption: logo with through through a browser
Caption: which is really cool
Caption: uh but today I'm going to be showing you
Caption: uh par P5 JS and Shader toy which are
Caption: two tools that create art in very
Caption: different ways and I'm going to sort of
Caption: speak through how those differ but both
Caption: tools are web-based both are freely
Caption: available don't require any
Caption: subscriptions or any payments and you
Caption: don't even have to create an account on
Caption: any of the sites you can just kind of
Caption: use them
Caption: there are there are comparisons that you
Caption: can draw between creative code or
Caption: creative or art to generated through
Caption: code and traditional art and I like to
Caption: view them as the programs that you use
Caption: or the apps that you use very much the
Caption: mediums much like canvases and stone and
Caption: wood where they determine largely the
Caption: thing you're going to create so you
Caption: don't you don't create a sculpture with
Caption: a canvas for example and you can sort of
Caption: view tools in the same sort of vein and
Caption: then the algorithms and the the methods
Caption: that you use to create these things the
Caption: code that you create that's your brushes
Caption: and your pens and your chisels
Caption: uh
Caption: and so I'm going to talk through some of
Caption: some of those today as we work through
Caption: some of the demos
Caption: um generative art is I think and I'll
Caption: sort of take a small tangent here and
Caption: speak of nfts like I wasn't going to do
Caption: but I generally think that gender of art
Caption: is a real genuine use case for nfts
Caption: packaging the code along with the
Caption: parameters to create the thing I think
Caption: is
Caption: is very valuable and I think is a real
Caption: um there's a real benefit
Caption: and a genuine use case for nfts
Caption: uh
Caption: processing with p5.js so p5.js is the
Caption: first of the tools I want to speak to
Caption: you about today and it's it's based on
Caption: processing it's a flavor of processing
Caption: and processing was developed in I think
Caption: 2001
Caption: as a
Caption: as a software literacy tool it's a it's
Caption: a Java based Graphics Library an IDE
Caption: that that you can draw stuff with it's
Caption: it is highly powerful and it's used for
Caption: things like simulations as well so it's
Caption: got a breadth everywhere from sort of
Caption: beginner level access to to very very
Caption: high level
Caption: the p5.js is a web implementation of
Caption: that as the name suggests leveraging
Caption: JavaScript
Caption: it does have a web editor or you can
Caption: build your own which I think is pretty
Caption: is pretty nifty
Caption: um as I mentioned it's it's really easy
Caption: to do it's really easy to get into and
Caption: it's reasonably well documented uh you
Caption: can there are enough similarities while
Caption: not a direct one-to-one Port of
Caption: processing the the similarities are
Caption: close enough that you could actually
Caption: leverage the documentation in tandem
Caption: it is I consider sort of a high level
Caption: language it abstracts a lot of the
Caption: difficulty and complexity in creating
Caption: some of this stuff quite well so for
Caption: example you can draw a circle you can
Caption: draw a square or if you're in 3D a cube
Caption: or a sphere and you'd also use vectors
Caption: and vectors is kind of we'll touch on
Caption: some of those but in a bit but having
Caption: that control really expands the
Caption: possibilities that you have
Caption: uh and it's a bit more like I say a bit
Caption: more high level than than shaders that
Caption: we'll touch on a bit later
Caption: you can like I say do 2D and 3D stuff uh
Caption: so
Caption: um we'll we'll speak through some of
Caption: those as well
Caption: to give you an example
Caption: uh these are all created with p5.js so
Caption: as you can see very different uh in
Caption: style very different in nature and
Caption: I could speak particularly for the for
Caption: the um the one on the right that took a
Caption: lot of time and a lot of effort it's
Caption: really interesting how that came about
Caption: and the author or the the artist
Caption: um posts a really good blog post on that
Caption: which which I'll share in the slide deck
Caption: as well
Caption: that they they talk about how they
Caption: actually created it and it's fascinating
Caption: to see that actually
Caption: um come to life and come to fruition
Caption: long processed many months
Caption: and of course you can create animations
Caption: and I think that's
Caption: um that's one of the the strongest draws
Caption: of this in terms of uh in terms of
Caption: comparisons with traditional art and
Caption: it's something I think we as as
Caption: developers as coders have have an
Caption: advantage and we can create some really
Caption: cool animations um with with things like
Caption: p5.js and Shader toy
Caption: so let's get on to some some demos right
Caption: Sans the technical difficulties
Caption: there we go
Caption: can you close that one
Caption: so
Caption: p5.js
Caption: you can go to built-in editor
Caption: uh like I said super super simple if you
Caption: want to create a circle create a circle
Caption: and we'll do it in the middle of the
Caption: screen so what's divided by two height
Caption: divided by two if I could type that'd be
Caption: great
Caption: and 50. and it's a radius of 50 or
Caption: diameter 50.
Caption: any credit Circle super easy you change
Caption: the color of the circle so change the
Caption: fill to I know uh red Maybe
Caption: because red
Caption: yeah
Caption: red so
Caption: super easy to use and I think that's one
Caption: of the biggest straws in terms of
Caption: getting into it and just getting into
Caption: creative art and trying to learn how to
Caption: to think creatively rather than problem
Caption: solve it's a really easy barrier really
Caption: low barrier to entry
Caption: um
Caption: but you can also create things like this
Caption: right and
Caption: this is an example of something I
Caption: created with in collaboration with the
Caption: guys at maker X when trying to I suppose
Caption: defect or visualize earthquakes in an
Caption: interesting fashion
Caption: and we use kind of the number of circles
Caption: that it would generate as as the the
Caption: magnitudes would reflect those and then
Caption: plot them randomly or into or perhaps in
Caption: a geographical location and align that
Caption: like that
Caption: but what's really interesting is that
Caption: there aren't any circles here these are
Caption: actually created just by creating
Caption: tangents tangents at regular intervals
Caption: and drawing a line and this is I think
Caption: where the real power we start to see the
Caption: real power or something like p5.js where
Caption: you can use vectors to to project these
Caption: things which are much more difficult to
Caption: do if you have to roll it yourself
Caption: so what I actually do here is I take a
Caption: point in a circle I project a vector on
Caption: One Direction added to the other side
Caption: and then draw a line between the two and
Caption: I just do that for everything for 360
Caption: times and it kind of draws a circle
Caption: uh and I'll look through through one of
Caption: the circle so it's still relatively
Caption: simple to do I'm not using any advanced
Caption: mathematics it's basic high school maths
Caption: and it creates some really interesting
Caption: stuff
Caption: but of course you can just keep creating
Caption: new versions
Caption: over and over
Caption: um or you could perhaps not even make it
Caption: random and you could take the circle out
Caption: and have it depicted elsewhere
Caption: the creative pot and this is where it
Caption: gets super super interesting is uh you
Caption: start off with something like this with
Caption: a simple idea and then you try to expand
Caption: upon it and you could perhaps create
Caption: something a bit more like this
Caption: and this is completely different in many
Caption: ways to to the other but the code is
Caption: almost identical so what I do here is
Caption: instead of creating uh line 360 lines to
Caption: create a circle make them random and I
Caption: give them all different colors of
Caption: different points and just draw them draw
Caption: a number of them and Vary the alpha
Caption: randomly as well so you get the sort of
Caption: stringy sort of look
Caption: uh
Caption: and of course oh if I was to remove the
Caption: seed
Caption: you can create and create
Caption: and create
Caption: all sorts of
Caption: different images and of course you can
Caption: constrain them so uh there I'm not
Caption: really doing anything anything to limit
Caption: where those things appear but you can
Caption: you can sort of do that and we'll get to
Caption: some examples that do that in a tick
Caption: um
Caption: but you can do something that's more
Caption: structured perhaps and something that
Caption: perhaps even mimics real life art so
Caption: like you're painting or something like
Caption: that
Caption: and this is an example that I pulled
Caption: together where I took a cityscape a city
Caption: um City skyline as uh as
Caption: um
Caption: as inspiration and I wanted to I started
Caption: off quite simply where I just had uh
Caption: true false
Caption: I thought about like that
Caption: and one of the things I really wanted to
Caption: experiment with was layering layering on
Caption: top of it to create this perspective and
Caption: adjusting the alpha at various levels to
Caption: to give that sort of perspective but
Caption: then of course that Evolution comes into
Caption: play and you're like well I wanted to
Caption: try I want to try play with bezier
Caption: curves or bezier Curves and so I added
Caption: clouds as bezier curves bezier curves
Caption: again another example of how p5gs makes
Caption: something that
Caption: could be quite mathematically
Caption: complex if you wanted it to be it
Caption: doesn't have to be mind you but it can
Caption: be and makes it really simple that's a
Caption: simple simple function to create it uh
Caption: yeah somewhere
Caption: busier
Caption: so I kind of create those but then I
Caption: thought well what if I want to make it
Caption: look like a paintbrush instead of
Caption: something that's solid like that I mean
Caption: that that will look cool and stuff but I
Caption: mean why not
Caption: this takes a bit of a bit of time
Caption: why not create to create a paintbrush
Caption: and the way I did that was now there
Caption: isn't a paintbrush you can't say hey
Caption: p5.js draw me a paintbrush or Draw this
Caption: in a paintbrush stroke pattern
Caption: um you have to create this manually and
Caption: that's just that's easy you take the
Caption: square and you PL take the pixels and
Caption: you just do one pixel at a time and
Caption: that's sort of why it takes a bit a bit
Caption: longer to do and we'll get into to how
Caption: this this is where one of the key
Caption: differentiates between this and Shader
Caption: toy that we'll talk about later sort of
Caption: comes into play
Caption: and then I thought well that doesn't
Caption: really look brush like right so you
Caption: don't get the brush stroke at the end
Caption: and I wanted to just get brush Strokes
Caption: so I added I add a little Randomness to
Caption: the length of each stroke so each line
Caption: is going up in a single pattern
Caption: and I'm just reduced just a minute or
Caption: randomizing the height of that line each
Caption: time to create a sort of brush stroke
Caption: and the palettes I mean you might might
Caption: have noticed that I have pallets for or
Caption: different palettes for everything and
Caption: that's just a list of of Json uh Json
Caption: hex values and I'll load them in
Caption: and then randomly pick one that's that's
Caption: as simple as it gets really
Caption: speaking of bezier Curves I think bezier
Caption: curves are are a beautiful illustration
Caption: of maths they
Caption: that they're really simple in in nature
Caption: but they can make some incredibly
Caption: interesting shapes and I sort of took
Caption: inspiration here from you know the world
Caption: windows screen savers and sort of kind
Caption: of bouncing around that was the
Caption: inspiration right and and it's
Caption: I haven't colored any of these and
Caption: that's that's I think the the next next
Caption: phase is sort of what do you do with
Caption: these to want to extend them so you take
Caption: something that's really simple in just
Caption: 40 lines of code and you can create
Caption: all sorts of different shapes
Caption: and you start to want to create a bit
Caption: your creative part takes over and you're
Caption: like well what can we do with that for
Caption: this particular instance I sort of took
Caption: one bezier curve and then just linked it
Caption: to another one but what if you made that
Caption: random at some in some way or what if
Caption: you had that deterministic in some other
Caption: fashion what if you added color what if
Caption: you added different shading to the
Caption: different lines then you start to get
Caption: some art right
Caption: um a noise so uh
Caption: speaking of Randomness there is there is
Caption: a lot of Randomness in Creative code and
Caption: there's sorts of there's a few different
Caption: ways you can approach that right and
Caption: there's you can have it as either
Caption: completely random between two values and
Caption: it'll pick something but sometimes you
Caption: need something a bit more nuanced a bit
Caption: a bit more subtle right and noise is a
Caption: great way to do that something like
Caption: purlin noise for example where it's a
Caption: gradient of of of Randomness it's
Caption: something you can use in this in when
Caption: you want something like this where
Caption: you're only incrementing a value by a
Caption: small amount from the last value every
Caption: time and you sort of iterate over that
Caption: map of that purlin noise and adjust the
Caption: value accordingly
Caption: very very powerful again something that
Caption: is natively built into p5.js
Caption: sorry uh speaking of rules I mentioned
Caption: rules earlier where you want to sort of
Caption: constrain stuff and I suppose this is
Caption: more sort of software engineering
Caption: developery type of stuff
Caption: but you could constrain stuff like
Caption: Circle packing and you could say well
Caption: don't have any circles over that don't
Caption: create circles another Circle and create
Caption: some interesting diminishing patterns
Caption: um
Caption: and you can then extend that again
Caption: evolutionary well what can you do with
Caption: that perhaps you have that in certain
Caption: shapes you could have that along a
Caption: bezier curve so you have a bezier curve
Caption: and have the the circles all pack along
Caption: that curve within a certain radius and
Caption: create lines like that
Caption: or maybe you just want to represent
Caption: represent Doge right
Caption: because because why not
Caption: and and this is a this is a really cool
Caption: example of just taking an image sampling
Caption: the pixel of where your point is and
Caption: then making the color of that Circle
Caption: that that pixel color and you can create
Caption: something like this and of course you
Caption: can you can adjust all of all of the
Caption: values and you can have uh circles be
Caption: bigger or smaller and you can I do have
Caption: to make some changes to this to make the
Caption: image a bit more legible because if you
Caption: have massive uh massive circles you then
Caption: start to have huge Circles of one color
Caption: and you can't really get that definition
Caption: you don't really tell you not really
Caption: tell what it is so I had to implement
Caption: something which would
Caption: grow it and then slow it down as it got
Caption: bigger so as the circle got bigger I
Caption: would slow the the growth down so that
Caption: it wouldn't really go past much a
Caption: certain size and it would give time for
Caption: more circles to fill in and pack it
Caption: foreign
Caption: taxes again so much like the logo
Caption: example I shared earlier but this time
Caption: with nice pretty colors
Caption: and I wanted to show this purely because
Caption: I want to show that the maths around it
Caption: is super super simple
Caption: and I think this is something which
Caption: initially
Caption: I found daunting when looking at
Caption: creative code I would see all these
Caption: things on Twitter all these things on
Caption: LinkedIn be like that looks really cool
Caption: but I'm sure that's really difficult to
Caption: do
Caption: and it's when you start to really dig
Caption: into it and you you even just look up
Caption: some you go into Wikipedia and you look
Caption: up what some of these equations look
Caption: like and they're not difficult but they
Caption: can create some really really
Caption: interesting patterns
Caption: um taking that a step further
Caption: and you can create
Caption: images like that that is the same
Caption: pattern just I'm now adjusting the size
Caption: of each of the circles and I'm coloring
Caption: it a bit differently
Caption: that's really it's the same code just a
Caption: bit different same thing a bit different
Caption: thank you
Caption: but it doesn't have to be all geometric
Caption: you can make stuff that's really random
Caption: really interesting and almost paint like
Caption: and this I sort of
Caption: I tried to to
Caption: replicate or reproduce a Jackson Pollock
Caption: painting So with lots of just sort of
Caption: paint everywhere in arbitrary ways
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: this is sort of what it comes up with
Caption: but of course the benefit being code is
Caption: you can create
Caption: as many as you want
Caption: and you can tell that they're all
Caption: slightly different in terms of brush
Caption: sizes and that's all determined by the
Caption: code so I could submit it to certain
Caption: brush sizes or brushes or I could make
Caption: it go wild
Caption: patterns and and you can introduce
Caption: patterns to it and there's a really
Caption: interesting article I read about taking
Caption: an image and using the values of those
Caption: images the color values of those images
Caption: to manipulate how the lines are drawn so
Caption: you end up having something that looks
Caption: like this but it has structure within it
Caption: I thought that was really really
Caption: interesting
Caption: um
Caption: but this is the this is really the uh
Caption: this particular example is the the
Caption: technique I really wanted to go in depth
Caption: with a bit more because you sort of look
Caption: at it and you can't it might be
Caption: difficult to see what's going on how you
Caption: create that
Caption: but when I found out how to create this
Caption: I was amazed how easy it actually was uh
Caption: and it's all very very logical and it's
Caption: easy to demonstrate as well
Caption: so you take a look at something like
Caption: this and
Caption: all it is is it's a it's a flow field
Caption: but it's created with vectors which I
Caption: mentioned earlier which again benefit of
Caption: p5.js
Caption: but that's what it looks like
Caption: so you take you take a grid you take a
Caption: canvas you plot it into grids and you
Caption: can adjust the size of the grid as much
Caption: as you want
Caption: you then plot some purlin noise over
Caption: that
Caption: and then take vectors based on that
Caption: purlin noise so if your noise is zero to
Caption: one and you relate that to a radius or a
Caption: um to a Direction
Caption: you then direct the vector in that way
Caption: and because Pearl and noise is
Caption: Progressive uh it's it's you start to
Caption: get the sort of
Caption: feel this this motion as you will so
Caption: it's sort of like forces being applied
Caption: and all of the all of the directions
Caption: that you see here are just are the
Caption: directions of the flow field influenced
Caption: by purlin noise
Caption: and you can create of course I think
Caption: I've got this randomized I think maybe
Caption: possibly
Caption: I do like that seed
Caption: oh
Caption: is it going to create the same one
Caption: yeah but I can take a better seat how's
Caption: that
Caption: perhaps
Caption: I mean you could put an any seed really
Caption: now I will I will confess there is a bit
Caption: of a bug in it and you'll see
Caption: occasionally you can see it here where
Caption: on the edges it sort of gets trapped
Caption: between two so again you get to you have
Caption: to do some problem solving as an
Caption: engineer and figure out well how do you
Caption: make
Caption: how do you adjust the the force or the
Caption: direction of those so that you don't end
Caption: up having these infinite loops on either
Caption: side
Caption: but of course it can be adjusted even
Caption: further so if you wanted to for example
Caption: uh have it go longer so right now I'm
Caption: constraining the time so it only has a
Caption: certain amount of time to create
Caption: and it's it's that's probably something
Caption: I should have called out it's the alpha
Caption: that makes it do that so it's like
Caption: putting a whole bunch of pixels on the
Caption: onto the screen and then adjusting the
Caption: alpha gradually over time as you as you
Caption: throw in more pixels and those pixels
Caption: kind of travel around and as they leave
Caption: more Trails you start to get thicker
Caption: thicker lines in the areas that they
Caption: travel
Caption: um but it's the vector at the heart of
Caption: it it's the vectors that really that
Caption: really help to make this possible
Caption: but again super super easy right there
Caption: is nothing that should stop anyone uh
Caption: even someone with very limited
Caption: development experience or programming
Caption: experience to do this sort of stuff
Caption: so it highly highly recommend people try
Caption: it out
Caption: cool
Caption: and then
Caption: no
Caption: yes
Caption: cool so uh
Caption: p5.js in summary is a is a fantastic
Caption: tool for pretty much anyone to get into
Caption: creative code
Caption: it's easy to uh it's easy to get into
Caption: it's well well documented
Caption: but it's also a really good tool for
Caption: anyone with
Caption: um with develop with Advanced
Caption: programming experience and the reason I
Caption: say that
Caption: is because I've only just scratched the
Caption: surface there is a breadth of of
Caption: capability there which you can leverage
Caption: I didn't even touch on the 3D stuff that
Caption: you can do but you can do 3D and it does
Caption: support shaders for example and you can
Caption: hook it up to all sorts of other sources
Caption: and it's fantastic for kids
Caption: um it if Loya was what we were taught
Caption: sort of 30 years ago
Caption: um this is is what kids should be taught
Caption: now in live view
Caption: uh
Caption: extra benefit the skills are
Caption: transferable so JS you can transfer that
Caption: shaders uh
Caption: shaders with Shader toy
Caption: so as I mentioned earlier I got into
Caption: unity and that introduced me to shaders
Caption: and shaders are a sea like see like-ish
Caption: language
Caption: um user C like C like language like J
Caption: um glsl and hlsl
Caption: they are they are high level languages
Caption: but I would liken them to lower level
Caption: languages than say um p5.js in that they
Caption: are assembly like it's not assembly by
Caption: any means but you you the way you have
Caption: to think about working with them is very
Caption: much assembly like
Caption: they're used in the graphics render
Caption: pipeline for 3D stuff and useful things
Caption: like lighting Shadows uh Reflections all
Caption: that kind of thing
Caption: um
Caption: uh there are several different types of
Caption: shaders by the way so vertex shaders
Caption: geometry shaders and fragment shaders
Caption: they all do different things we're going
Caption: to focus primarily on fragment shaders
Caption: today
Caption: and what's really interesting is these
Caption: are some examples that were created
Caption: there isn't any 3D geometry in there
Caption: there are no triangles there are no
Caption: meshes there are no no quads no vertices
Caption: whatsoever that's all drawn effectively
Caption: drawn to the screen and a call out to
Caption: inio kiles who did the rainforest he's
Caption: got a fantastic YouTube video on how we
Caption: made that
Caption: absolutely worth a watch
Caption: and we'll get on to some more demos
Caption: before I get too far and I just want to
Caption: give a quick a quick sort of uh
Caption: Shakedown of what what shaders are in a
Caption: typical 3D environment you have a mesh
Caption: that's made up of vertices and some
Caption: lines between them creating triangles
Caption: then you can apply a material to it but
Caption: of course the material doesn't have any
Caption: value until you apply some light to it
Caption: so you get some light and you get a
Caption: material you can then also provide some
Caption: directional lighting and some shading on
Caption: the material
Caption: it's all of them all of the material
Caption: stuff is is the shadery bits is that
Caption: we're going to be talking about so we're
Caption: not going to worry about the vertices
Caption: today we're just going to be talking
Caption: about the shaders
Caption: sorry about the the
Caption: um the fragment Shader
Caption: uh I'm going to skip these examples
Caption: because we're running low on time but
Caption: head over to Shader toy to check those
Caption: out because they're really really
Caption: interesting
Caption: um but the thing I really wanted to uh
Caption: the the method or or the technique I
Caption: wanted to share with you with regards to
Caption: shaders is Ray marching that is how
Caption: those images were done and it's a really
Caption: interesting technique to apply to um to
Caption: creative coding in general and it's you
Caption: can use that to create proper scenes or
Caption: you can create it create fractals and
Caption: all sorts of interesting stuff with them
Caption: and the whole notion of it is
Caption: um effectively looking at looking at a
Caption: scene and measuring the distance between
Caption: the camera and something in the scene
Caption: figuring out what's closer and rendering
Caption: that and you render it pixel by pixel
Caption: I think that's that's the key thing to
Caption: to bear in mind with shaders is you are
Caption: not actually saying hey draw me a circle
Caption: draw me a square draw me a cube you are
Caption: saying I want this color at this color
Caption: pixel at coordinate X Y to be this color
Caption: uh and that is all very mathematically
Caption: or can be very mathematically intensive
Caption: um so it's a bit more daunting to get
Caption: into and we'll get into that a little
Caption: bit
Caption: um but Ray marching is a process of
Caption: um determining the distance between
Caption: objects in the scene and your camera
Caption: so I created this little sort of demo
Caption: thing to sort of show how that might
Caption: work and I'm going to turn off all those
Caption: so say you started off with uh so you
Caption: started off with your camera in the
Caption: middle of the scene
Caption: and we have array that's going out from
Caption: the scene
Caption: now so you add some objects into the
Caption: scene right
Caption: you want to you want to try and figure
Caption: out which so if I'm looking in this
Caption: direction what am I supposed to render
Caption: to the screen I'm supposed to render
Caption: number one at this particular pixel
Caption: so
Caption: how do we do that well we draw lines we
Caption: try to we go through we Loop through the
Caption: entire entire scene and say well how far
Caption: are you how far are you how far are you
Caption: and you try to draw the close but you
Caption: don't want to draw it to the to the
Caption: origin of that you want to draw it to
Caption: the origin of the surface of that and
Caption: that's where stuff gets interesting
Caption: because that uses sine distance fields
Caption: to calculate where the surface of it is
Caption: based on what the center or the origin
Caption: is of that object
Caption: and you do that iteratively so you take
Caption: further and further steps as you get out
Caption: into the into the scene to figure out
Caption: when you've hit something so as you can
Caption: see here I haven't actually hit anything
Caption: because I haven't reached my minimum
Caption: distance
Caption: that I to get to the object I haven't
Caption: realized that hey I'm actually at a
Caption: surface
Caption: but if you extend that further you start
Caption: to see it
Caption: expand
Caption: and you can see where you're starting to
Caption: actually hit things
Caption: um and you return that back to your uh
Caption: back to your code and you say I'm going
Caption: to display pixel of this color at this
Caption: coordinate
Caption: so in a nutshell that is that is
Caption: remarking and that's used through
Caption: each of through the rest of these these
Caption: um these examples
Caption: I created a basic bootstrap Ray marching
Caption: Shader which will be in in in the
Caption: resources at the end of the slideshow
Caption: uh but essentially all it is is a basic
Caption: uh algorithm to do ray marching and the
Caption: magic here all happens if they forget
Caption: the normal calculating
Caption: um happens sort of here
Caption: and for this example the
Caption: the distance for a sphere
Caption: if you want to calculate the science
Caption: distance field for the sphere is
Caption: calculated with this right now the
Caption: benefit is you don't have to worry about
Caption: having to work all this out some some
Caption: very smart people have already worked
Caption: out the sign distance fields for almost
Caption: every shape you can think of you then
Caption: take those and combine them and you
Caption: combine them using Boolean operators so
Caption: you can Union them you can subtract them
Caption: you can multiply them or add them
Caption: and that's that's effectively how you
Caption: would create a scene and for example
Caption: I created this for DDD Perth
Caption: where
Caption: it's just some lights going around but
Caption: there is no geometry in the scene right
Caption: this is all just I'm picking a pixel uh
Caption: in a screen based on this distance for
Caption: something and I can even show you what
Caption: that might look like if you take the the
Caption: O here for example
Caption: and this is when demo Gods strike me
Caption: down
Caption: uh so if I was to just return say
Caption: um the main o right so I'm returning the
Caption: distance to the main o
Caption: so yeah there we go and let's get a
Caption: sphere because that's all I started off
Caption: with but then what if I what if I
Caption: returned the minimum no actually I don't
Caption: think I'd do the maximum work
Caption: uh for the maximum value
Caption: of the main o and say the whole right
Caption: oh
Caption: Oh wrong one my bad
Caption: hold on let demo God strike me down
Caption: there we go
Caption: so what I've done here is I've
Caption: effectively negated uh the the main o so
Caption: the main o is no longer visible and only
Caption: the D's within it are right
Caption: but you can create a mask actually if I
Caption: do mask
Caption: that might
Caption: oops
Caption: this is why you don't do live coding
Caption: people
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: by doing this what I've done is I've
Caption: I've created a an intersection between
Caption: the O and the mask that I've got for the
Caption: circle in the middle
Caption: and that's how you would you would
Caption: create a scene based out of
Caption: uh these Primitives that you would
Caption: create with sign distance fields
Caption: and it when you sort of when you start
Caption: to look at that you start to really
Caption: appreciate what some of these more
Caption: complex or complex images really take to
Caption: to create
Caption: it's a far more
Caption: I appreciate that experience a whole lot
Caption: more
Caption: of course the benefit is you can do
Caption: stuff like this as well
Caption: if you were to try and create this sort
Caption: of thing with a with traditional sort of
Caption: 3D geometry uh your machine would be on
Caption: fire
Caption: um and and so but you can you can do
Caption: this because you can do this in shaders
Caption: because you're not affecting you're not
Caption: affecting geometry you are effectively
Caption: changing the shape of the environment
Caption: you're affecting the environment not the
Caption: geometry itself so this is this this
Caption: whole
Caption: um field of spheres is created just by
Caption: by applying a modulo
Caption: to the sphere and it creates all of
Caption: these all these spheres
Caption: the the intersections or the uh The
Caption: Operators that I mentioned earlier and
Caption: because you're using sine distance
Caption: Fields allow you to do cool stuff like
Caption: if this this thing is close to this
Caption: thing take us point in this point and if
Caption: it's close enough together do something
Caption: with it that's how you sort of get this
Caption: uh this glob effect
Caption: um I I'm really Keen to try and make
Caption: this into sort of a metabols type of
Caption: thing or like a lava lamp I think that'd
Caption: be pretty cool
Caption: um
Caption: but you don't have to just do you don't
Caption: have to just do
Caption: sort of shapes and stuff again another
Caption: mathematical
Caption: Ingenuity or another mathematical
Caption: principle the mandelbrot set
Caption: and it's a depiction of it just zooming
Caption: in and it's
Caption: constantly evolving
Caption: and shaders are really good at doing
Caption: this because it you get to Leverage The
Caption: GPU to process and crunch some of these
Caption: things which is really effective and you
Caption: get to do some cool stuff with distances
Caption: from from various places
Caption: so all those are all those available on
Caption: Shader toy to take a look at
Caption: nope
Caption: so that did it work did it work no
Caption: it is changing here like it's changed
Caption: it's kind of semi-changing there but I
Caption: don't know
Caption: I don't know man this is
Caption: he just goes to show you no matter how
Caption: much you prepare tell you what
Caption: just
Caption: that uh
Caption: do that and go back
Caption: oh maybe I've just got to do that
Caption: no it's just not moving at all
Caption: like a moving slides here but it's not
Caption: moving
Caption: nope
Caption: oh there we go that'll do it
Caption: uh all that five uh five okay
Caption: yay there you go so uh sorry about that
Caption: Shader toy requires a shift in mindset
Caption: and I think that's the key takeaway for
Caption: Shader toy in particular it's definitely
Caption: not as approachable as something like
Caption: php5.js it is mathematically intensive
Caption: you do have to think about how how you
Caption: want to solve problems and that can be a
Caption: bit daunting but it can also be very
Caption: rewarding as I personally prefer
Caption: creating stuff in in Shader toy and
Caption: creating shaders they they just sort of
Caption: Tickle My Fancy I suppose
Caption: um
Caption: but it also offers great opportunities
Caption: so things like fractals for example and
Caption: that's that's fair field you just can't
Caption: realistically do that in something like
Caption: ip5.js
Caption: um and I like the challenge right
Caption: but at the end of the day it's Different
Caption: Strokes to different folks there is no
Caption: best tool so use whatever suits you so
Caption: use whichever is going to fulfill your
Caption: needs
Caption: and think about what you want to create
Caption: what is the best tool going to be for
Caption: that
Caption: and more importantly I think try to
Caption: Master One I've tried to to sort of do
Caption: both and that's been that's been a
Caption: challenge I I don't think I've got very
Caption: good at either of them I'm still
Caption: learning
Caption: um so try to try to master one I've seen
Caption: I think some of that stuff that that I'm
Caption: showing you today some of the other
Caption: examples
Caption: um those are from people who have
Caption: focused on on mastering one of them
Caption: so the key takeaways for today uh you
Caption: don't have to be an artist to create art
Caption: and I think it was Ralph Waldo Emerson
Caption: who said every artist was first in
Caption: amateur
Caption: so like try it don't be scared to uh
Caption: pick the tool that suits you
Caption: uh and experiment there is no right way
Caption: to do it and the creative part of this I
Caption: think is the most important lesson in
Caption: the coding it's being feeling free to
Caption: try and do new things
Caption: um I just want to call out that I've all
Caption: of this and everything I've learned I've
Caption: been standing on the shoulders of giants
Caption: and in particular these individuals
Caption: and
Caption: especially the likes of Dan schiffman
Caption: who's got a who's authored a book called
Caption: nature of code which is absolutely worth
Caption: a read and in your keyless who is just a
Caption: master at Shader toy
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: alrighty guys thank you so much first of
Caption: all Brandon we've had a few technical
Caption: difficulties and we'll get that off but
Caption: thank you all for coming
Caption: um just a reminder we do have morning
Caption: tea in the foyer um so if everyone can
Caption: make a move there that would be
Caption: fantastic